this guy concludes his book
by talking about culture wars and
and you kind of grew up in the middle of
what we call the culture of wars
and some of this is actually a little
bit before
you came on the scene but it's recent
history and it kind of dictates
the landscape for discussions about
religion today that
you guys are going to be engaged in
throughout
the rest of your life because religion
is not going to go away it's going to
continue to play an important role in
american life
and culture and politics it's going to
morph into different
you know frameworks and um
focuses than we're seeing with this
textbook
but it's guaranteed it's going to be
around it's going to be an important
force
and when we talk about the culture wars
all right is this something that you
guys are
familiar with it was kind of it was a
term that was really big in the 90s
not so many people use it today but are
you have you heard about this
this notion of culture wars
nobody yeah it's probably not talked
that much about
oftentimes we frame this in terms of
conservatives
versus liberals and
who would we line up on both sides of
this
like if we're going to pick parties
political parties should we line up
conservatives is mostly republicans
um liberals
democrats and we have other parties
right
but they're pretty small they don't have
a very big role in american life
they they can't do much in politics like
the
constitution party would be over here
the green party would be over here
but they really don't don't don't do
that much and these parties
are coalitions they bring together
people belonging to a lot of groups
that's why they actually have the power
that they do
and they engage in a lot of
formation of opinions as we call it in
the media
in schools so you know there's a lot of
hot button issues
you know that divide people like for
example abortion
um this is one that you know the
republicans and democrats are constantly
fighting about right
what else what are some of the other key
issues that people get really hot about
yeah i think one of the biggest ones
today is gay rights yeah
specifically um the the marriage
question right
that's the one that probably gets the
most press um we'll also have their hand
up
somebody else had their hands up um yeah
um i just wanna say like illegal
immigration okay yeah that one it's
interesting
because there's people in both parties
that kind of seem to agree with each
other
there is a strong nativist element still
in american politics of you know
send them ferner's home even though just
about everybody's descended from an
immigrant to one form or another
um and nobody's been able to work out a
good
good solution for that what are some
other yeah
uh guns gun control
okay yeah got a death penalty
another big one
a lot of news lately when the execution
took a long time to actually
pull off um
what are some that some of these don't
involve religion quite so much like the
gun control that tends to be about the
second amendment
um death penalty
uh religion does get involved there but
that's that's where you sometimes see
people who are quite conservative
actually being against it on religious
grounds
what are some uh some areas where
religion really gets
right in the middle of it that people
get worked up about
besides abortion of course yeah stem
cell research
yeah there hasn't been a lot of talk
about that recently but you know
about 10 years ago five years ago um
you know let's not just put down stem
cell let's put down uh any sort of um
use of human
hearts
when is it okay to use bits and pieces
of human beings
to do research to fix things
you know when isn't it that's that's an
issue that's going to get really big
during your lifetime it's going to
assume a much greater role
what about in schools
what are what are some of the things
where yeah
okay yeah pledge of allegiance i i'm
going to put stuff here but i don't
need to say that the democrats are for
or something like that we just ran out
of room
um
so the pledge of allegiance uh what else
what are other school controversies yeah
um
public spaces say again prayer and
public space
oh yeah you know it's good that you say
public spaces
because it's uh not just
schools um people are getting all worked
up now because the supreme court sort of
reaffirmed the
legitimacy of beginning governmental
functions of the prayer
yeah it's actually uh it was okay in the
use of secretary prayers but it's okay
to invoke the name of god or jesus
christ in prayers
where i was going to go with this is
that this has been the case for a long
time ago
there there was a case back you know um
having to do with invocations uh for the
senate
years and years back where they said
it's okay to begin with a prayer because
it serves some secular purpose
there are case laws on both sides you're
right i don't want to get too bogged
down in this i'm bringing this up as
an example of a controversial issue that
came up recently
but here's here's one of the things
where you can see a supreme court making
a big difference
school kids there's no possibility they
don't consider that
for adults they consider what is the
purpose you're right
case law waivers back and forth
you're not going to find a lot of super
coherent logic in supreme court
decisions about
really about anything but especially
about religion
um but they do open up a wider space for
this
and they have her you know since the 70s
than they do for with kids
so public spaces it's good to talk in
larger terms of them
that's another school issue school
prayer
pledge of allegiance yeah uh teaching
evolution
that's huge
teaching evolution
or let me just put dot dot because it
could be intelligent design or
creation science you know creationism
are you going to teach them side by side
or you can teach evolution as a theory
but not establish facts
you know there's all these different
permutations on it what textbooks are
you going to use
how are you going to test this sort of
stuff that's a big issue
sex ed education is another big issue
too what should you be teaching about
sexuality
we could you know we can multiply these
um
one of the things that this guy wants to
focus on is the development
of what he calls the
new religious right and i
i have to say looking at this chapter
it's a little bit unbalanced
because he's mostly you know cautioning
about how dangerous this is
i would say the religious left is is
they they do just as much
you know skewing things politically um
but he's focused on that and he's
telling an interesting story which is
where did this actually come from is
this an expression of all these other
things we've been studying this semester
so that's going to bring everything to
to kind of a close or not
and he begins by talking about the
puritan strain in american religion and
culture
and how eventually that comes back in
he talks about these great awakenings um
and some of the key themes
that you see you know over and over
again
in the course of these great awakenings
some people in religious studies want to
call what happened in the 1970s the
third great awakening in the 1980s
the rise of the religious right
so what are we actually talking about
here here's some of the
some of the key themes just to review
the puritans thought that earthly
society is founded on divine law
that you need to have some sort of
religious basis
and then secular society and secular law
would not necessarily
come directly from that but it would be
modeled after that
and they saw themselves as modeling
themselves after
israel you know the israel of the
old testament which had this covenantal
relation with god
they also focused a lot on education the
puritans
were important in getting the respect
for public education here in the united
states established
the clergy played an influential role in
their society but not
in a directly political way they it was
more
cultural it was more part of the society
and then it talks about the great
awakening of the 1740s is stuff we
covered early in the semester
there was a development of a
distinctively american style of
religious
and civic interaction and he you know he
gives you a lot of these examples and he
says
what was being played out here was an
illustration of this theme of communitas
or community
the disruption of established social
structure
by new forces creating a new experience
of community
so you know the conservatives whenever
we use this term conservative we got to
be a little bit careful
about what we mean do we mean people who
just are trying to keep things exactly
the same do we need
people who are trying to go back to an
earlier time
do we mean people who are trying to
create something new
which incorporates features of an
earlier time
which were lost in where we currently
are
and are being sort of reappropriated in
the new present all of those are
things you can tie in with conservatives
in a certain respect this will sound a
little paradoxical
liberals at certain points in history
can be the conservatives because when
they're actually dominant
for example on abortion uh who are the
the conservatives in the sense that they
want to keep it just the same exactly
the way it is
liberals they you know they want to you
know keep roe versus wade in place and
all these other decisions
so you know these terms are kind of
shifting we have to be careful about
what we mean by them
the religious right that he's talking
about is doing something
that happened way back then with you
know the great awakenings
which was to do what i was talking about
over here let me actually sort of put
this on the board
this kind of a chart form
um
we got the past and
the present or the recent past
and then the future
not too far off
and
you know you've got some sort of
structure of society
at this point society with its norms
and culture and then there's presumably
some sort of change
and we have presence society and culture
and the way that that progressives want
to see this
is well we just move we keep on moving
and it just keeps getting
better and better and better
and we just have you know newer society
and culture so you know think about
the theme of civil rights well you know
we started in america with not too many
people having civil rights at all
it's not just say women and blacks
native americans too but
unless you actually own land in most of
the colonies you could you didn't get to
vote
and you know that got they would like
lower the amount and each time that they
lowered the amount there'd be somebody
said everything's going to go to hell if
you do this
you know but they did it and then you
know eventually
pretty much everybody who can
satisfy certain requirements gets to
vote and but there's still some people
left out
then they expanded even more and it gets
expanded even more
same thing with thinking about
protecting people because of their
identity um racism you know was
an integral part of american culture for
a long time
and then we started moving towards a
society
where um it was contested where they
started saying
look you can't act this way and it
happened all across
the board not just you know legally it
happened with movies like
um what is it that one called guess
who's coming to dinner
uh ashlyn kutcher and bernie macri did
it originally was sydney pottier
movies like that helped to undo racism
because they show you know this this uh
this black guy coming to dinner
and the you know basically racist white
parents
having to come to terms with the fact
that he's a person
that produced changes are there still
things to overcome
you know this isn't sort of the
progressive way of looking at it
a conservative way of looking at it
would be more like this where
you take some of the norms and culture
or institutions and you have an updated
version of
and you know in the case of racism uh
there's not an awful lot of people
arguing that we ought to like you know
we need to revive racism
that was a big mistake um but in terms
of other things like the sense of
community
or reducing you know generational
dependency on welfare
things like that there are people who
are saying look it was better back in
the old days
and obviously we can't just turn the
clock back it needs to be some new form
but that's going to be a radical change
from the present and that's what a lot
of
conservatives in the last
40 years have been doing and this is
actually what happened during the first
great awakening as well
so this pattern is pretty old
um your book goes through a bunch of
different
you know interesting examples but i'm
going to skip over
a lot of those and just hit on a few
particularly important ones remember
when we talked about the benevolent
empire
this interwalking set of institutions
largely expressing
evangelical protestants america
it was carried out through culture not
through legislation
it was an attempt to make america into a
christian nation
not by actually making it you know
legally required
but by you might say overloading every
every place that was possible so imagine
like you know
with respect to school prayer some of
the ways you can kind of get around it
sometimes you're having clubs you know
you could like leave the school grounds
now imagine that the movement started to
to like every place we go
um kids are going to just like walk off
at recess and start praying
if they if enough of them did something
about it probably they
they just have to be accepted because
you know that's typically what we do
um that's sort of like what the
benevolent empire was doing
and it was also oriented against the
other
and who was the other back then well
southern slaveholders
and we're pretty much all agreed that
that you know that was an other that
needed to be
another and you know not too many people
other than southern slaveholders
were really that upset when when their
way of life disappeared
um but who else catholics
um non-religious people
thomas jefferson was turned into kind of
a a
bad guy you know because he's this dazed
figure
the mormons when they come on the scene
and this process continues eventually by
the 1920s though we see that
that these these forces lose a lot of
their
their ability to get things done the
benevolent empire kind of breaks up
in part because uh those who were
excluded didn't want to be excluded
so they couldn't accept that that
particular configuration
uh and in part because there were
certain landmark events think about
prohibition
prohibition was the last thing
on which evangelicals could actually get
together
across the board along with progressive
elements
and get some legislation passed
pretty much everything else that we can
look at has been
you know small potatoes compared to that
they've never had that sort of power
again now
throughout the 19 you know 30s 40s 50s
60s
it was liberal protestantism that was
dominating
the catholic church of course is doing
its own thing over there but then they
go through their own sort of
liberalization with vatican ii
you know everything starts changing the
priest actually starts you know
facing the congregation they start doing
masses in the vernacular
they become more socially engaged
remember we talked about the end of the
catholic ghetto
and then the 1960s themselves happened
with the sexual revolution
in the vietnam war and the reaction
against
uh american civil religion these are all
parts of the story that we've told so
far
and what this leads to is
the liberals don't win because the
liberals we're always you sort of
modernizing
bit by bit makes make you know sort of
short change
uh uh reforms and they could be
expressed through all sorts of mainline
denomination churches
um the conservatives didn't win
the radicals who are you know sort of
turned down the system
they come into the scene a lot of young
people leave
the mainline churches may either go to
become secular
or they become you know radicalized in a
different way they become conservative
so your book talks about jimmy carter
who now we think of as a very very left
figure very much
you know a progressive he was actually
seen
as sort of a conservative back then he
was an evangelical he was from the south
he was squeaky clean as opposed to you
know that dirty nixon who had really
turned
a lot of stuff um so when he comes in
that's part of the beginning of the
story he wasn't conservative enough of
course
in many respects he actually became much
less conservative as time went on
um so much so that he actually became a
he started doing things that presidents
just didn't do like criticizing
sitting presidents in the last
presidency
before before obama wish presidency
there's there's some key themes that
your book focuses on that are worth
pointing out
with respect to the new religious right
it talks about entrepreneurial
evangelical or fundamentalist clergy
what does that mean to be an
entrepreneur this is kind of a funny
thing to say about religion
any of you want to be entrepreneurs
what is it to be an entrepreneur
it's kind of a fancy term comes from
french
yeah like go out and start your own
thing exactly that's it
you you uh instead of joining a
corporation working your way up through
the institution
you say well hell i can sell that i can
i can actually talk to people i can
you know satisfy customers let me go out
and do that
and there was quite a bit of that in in
religion there's been a lot of that
since the first great awakening george
whitefield was
an entrepreneur in that way and so
that's been
something that's been uh central to to
american religion
uh you talked about the revival of the
jeremiah's harmonic form
jeremiah is one of these sort of helen
brimstone sermons of
how everything has gone to to pot the
nation is going to suffer
you know every once in a while there'll
be some conservative preacher who'll say
well you know
this thing happened because you let gay
marriage occur
uh it's god's judgment on the nation
that's what they mean by a jeremiah
an idealization of various eras and
aspects of early american culture
including the founding fathers that's
this thing again of going back to the
past
and saying we're not going to make
everything look like the past
but we want to bring some things that
have been lost in the present from the
past and put them into a new
modernized form
proclivity for defining and demonizing
enemies communist was the enemies for a
long time
secular humanists for a long time
muslims served that purpose for a lot of
people after
after 9 11 with you know the war on
terror
polarization of the american population
what does polarization mean
we live in a polarized society right now
yeah it's like
neither both sides are completely at
ends and don't want to really work with
each other
yeah this has become sort of the stance
quote
for where we are now it wasn't always
like that
it used to be that you could you could
you know appoint supreme court justices
without everybody going over their
record you know the fine-tooth comb
and saying this is going to be the end
of the world or this is going to be the
best thing possible
people didn't always vote along party
lines but that's become the norm now
it's gotten so bad that dating sites
have actually noticed
that people on dating sites will
look at other people's political
affiliations and they'll say i just want
to
vote
i won't date a democrat or i won't date
a republican
that was never the case before people
could you know if there were some people
who would be kind of a stickler
i wouldn't marry uh you know dirty
whatever
but most people were a bit more um
how'd you put a bit more rational about
that sort of thing a bit less emotional
social media has kind of contributed to
that this is actually considered to be
enough of a problem that i've been to
conferences we're trying to figure out
how could we use social media
not to create these silos where
everybody's you know talking to each
other and posting
you know pro this
stuff and ante this stuff in this silo
and how can we get people to actually
have you know real political discourse
turns out it's really really difficult
it's tough to do in facebook
and have you ever had a a bad facebook
argument
about politics one of your friends or
seen one
how irrational people can get
people defriend each other over that you
know
so we're living in a polarized uh
society
where both sides tend to demonize the
other side
moral endorsement of the free market
goes along with the religious rights
preoccupation with issues of sexual
morality
reaffirmation of traditional gender
roles a focus on education has one of
the battlegrounds
one of the places where they're right
education is a battleground
because you know you're talking about
what values you're teaching
young people who oftentimes don't have a
lot of
critical awareness and may take that as
being
the norm for better for worse
promotion of alternatives to public
education all these sorts of things
are part of the the religious right
then towards the end he starts you know
remember those those themes we talked
about at the beginning
like you know american exceptionalism or
immigration
or pluralism populism
he talks about how each of those ends up
being represented in the current
situation that we find ourselves
but we're not going to go into all those
examples
one of the things that he he does sort
of stress that i
i like towards the end is
that um
he says america's past us does will
offer some resources for hope
you know do we have to say ah this is
this is
not a good situation we need something
radically different
or do do we look at the past once we
actually understand it
and go back and say yeah you know maybe
we do need to reappropriate this in
order to think about you know for
example
um this is one example of many what's
one of the best
predictors of the success of children
that comes from
family issues yeah
whether or not the parents are married
with the time the children
were born that's that's a big one then
there's things like
the parents read you know um is the
father
actually there and engaged with the
children
that turns out to have huge effects on
drug use
school performance uh age
you know where people are becoming
sexually active
for boys and for girls in different ways
um now you know if you were gonna
nobody's saying well then
obviously the legislation must you know
like keep all the dads there don't let
the
dads become absentee fathers or anything
like that
but if if you live in a society that
stresses personal
choice as being the highest thing which
tends to be where
liberals or progressives actually are
and says traditional sexual sexual
morality
marriage we can make of that whatever we
like
everybody should be free to do whatever
they're going to do that's not actually
able
to address that problem i'm not saying
that you know the conservatives have
done a very good job in
addressing that problem either their
divorce rates are just about as high as
everybody else's
but there may be resources for looking
at
how things not in an idealized way but
in a real historical way how things used
to be what was successful in the past
can we actually bring that in new forms
into the present
um that's what he's suggesting this book
but not just about you know say
fatherhood but about all sorts of
religious themes
even american exceptionalism american
exceptionalism is this view that somehow
the united states is different than
other places
that's probably a crazy thing to think
in many respects
we're not better than other places
moral terms um
we're not particularly well educated in
comparison to some other places
we have a greater degree of inequality
than most other developed countries
but there are some things that are kind
of extraordinary about this place
you know we ought to think about is
there anything to this idea that's still
worth holding on to
still worth saving there are reasons why
even though they may not like you know
the current you know or past political
administrations
why people overseas say there's some
really great things about america why
they want to
emigrate here that's something that's
worth rethinking
this notion of american exceptionalism
and there's all sorts of ideas like that
that we've covered this semester that we
could apply this
same thing to that's where he ends he
says
the american tradition does offer
resources for
addressing the propensities of americans
to see themselves as this you know
central nation the central people
and then he talks about lincoln who
noted that in the second inaugural
address that that doesn't you know
that's not an easy thing to sound out
you can't figure out exactly what god's
plans are
what god wants for you he's talking
about the civil war and how both sides
you know
pray to the same god use the same bible
and we're also claiming destiny for
themselves
so that's something worth keeping in
mind as we as we close the semester as
we look at
you know religious conservatives but
also religious liberals because they
they all
do have a tendency to read the divine
plan into their own political agendas